لا أستطيع أن أرى ولكن يمكنني سماع العالم من
حولي يقابل برايان ، وهو معروف بأنه
أفضل
سائق دراجة جبلية أعمى تمامًا عندما كنت أصغر سنًا ، كان
لدي رؤية وظيفية ولعبت الرياضة
وكنت أحلم بأن أصبح رياضيًا محترفًا
ثم فجأة عندما كان في الرابعة عشرة من عمره
لقد فقد بصره تمامًا على
مدار 3 أشهر فشلت أعصابه البصرية
لسبب غير مفهوم وكل ما كان يراه
هو الظلام ولم يكن قادرًا على ركوب الدراجة
أو المشاركة في الألعاب الرياضية التي كان
يتمتع بها ذات مرة ولم أستطع لعب الهوكي واضطررت إلى
التوقف عن التزلج  لم يعد بإمكانه قراءة
لوحة الفصل الدراسي بعد أن تقلص العالم الذي أعيش فيه ،
كان عليه أن يجد طريقة جديدة
للتنقل في العالم ، وجد عصاه
محدودة ولكن عندما تعلم أن
ينقر لسانه ، تغير عالمه مرة أخرى
للأفضل ولم يمض وقت طويل  حتى
غامر بالعودة للخارج
، افتقدت حقًا ركوب الدراجة وأردت حقًا
أن أكون نشطًا ، لم أكن أعرف
كيف أفعل ذلك كراكب أعمى كان
هدفًا بالنسبة لي الخروج من الترادف والحصول
على تجربة أن أكون قادرًا
لتجربة دراجتي الخاصة ، كل شيء يبدأ
بضغطة ، أنا شخص مبصر ،
يعلقها بإطاره ويوجهها
إلى عجلة الدراجة ، ستصدر عجلة الدراجة
ضوضاء في صوت نتبعه بينما
لا نزال نضغط بنشاط في النهاية على
براين  بالدراجة الجبلية
وحدها وبدون ربطة عنق مضغوطة عندما أقود
دراجتي إلى أسفل الجبل ، نفس
الشيء الذي تستخدمه الخفافيش لتحديد الموقع بالصدى يمكنني أن
أجعل إشارة السونار الخاصة بي من خلال
نقرة لسان أبدأ بمحاولة
العثور على الكائن الأبعد في  المسافة
ثم تجميع العالم معًا
بأشياء أقرب وأقرب ، يجب أن
يدخل براين حالة تأملية تقريبًا
ويظل شديد التركيز ، كل شيء يجب
أن يترك عقلي وهذه الأصوات
ترسم صورة
بها عالم حي من الصور الصوتية
لم يحتفظ بها  شغفه تجاه نفسه على
الرغم من أنه ساعد في تعليم أكثر
من آلاف الأشخاص لسماع عالمهم أكبر قليلاً ،
هذا شيء قابل للتعليم يمكن لأي شخص
القيام بذلك ويسعدني أن أريهم
يركبون دراجتي كان  شيء لم أفكر مطلقًا في
أنني سأتمكن من فعله مرة أخرى ، والآن بعد
أن أفعل ذلك ، فإنه يعد مثالًا رائعًا
لتحدي الأفكار المسبقة